Bueno chicos bienvenidos al
ya hemos terminado
el primer workshop que ha sido muy chulo,
muy interesante
de cómo conectar personas para de cómo
pues el la salud mental en plan
y ahora estamos comiendo
y a esperar a las 2 de la mañana a las 2 de la mañana.
Bueno nosotras hemos llegado aquí esta mañana
en el autoboard de Bruselas
que es enorme,
o sea es chulísimo,
me ha flipado
y hemos tenido aquí 1 conexión
a he enseñado 1 vídeo que pondrán en abril,
la campaña del alexiano,
me he emocionado,
la verdad que era 1 vídeo superbonito
y y ya lo veréis cuando ya lo veréis,
o sea os VA a tocar la fibra totalmente
y yo creo que VA a animar 1 montón de gente a que vote.
La verdad está
superchulo, o sea mirar cuánta gente
saluda chicas
maqui haciendo 1 poquito de Network,
¿qué opina?
Está muy chulo todo, hay gente de todos los países,
hay gente muy top
y sí, la verdad es que sí,
ahora tenemos 1 break para 1 coffee,
1 dulcecito
y a seguir trabajando con la democracia europea.
a mí la comida yo preferiría la dieta mediterránea,
pero bueno, aquí se acepta porque estamos en Bélgica,
hay de gente de Italia, de Austria,
de Grecia, de Bulgaria.
Bueno bueno, esto es literalmente
lo que pasa cuando sacan a 2 cordobesas de su Ciudad
y la llevan a la capital de la Unión Europea,
aquí de descanso.
Mirad Qué fondo tan chulo fuera del autoboard
of the Breaking brucells.
¿No? Que no en la Comisión Europea,
¿eh? Acabamos de estar en el Parlamento Europeo.
Hemos estado saludando
a unos amigos que Han venido hoy aquí también
y nada, ya vamos a volver.
Hemos estado también en la Comisión Europea
saludando a otros amigos aquí.
1 vuelta por las instituciones, claro.
Claro que aquí hay muchos
eventos organizados estos días
y gente quedan muy importantes. 79 días,
79 días para votar en las elecciones. ¿Cuándo?
¿Cuándo? ¿Cuándo?
¿09 de junio? ¡Bravo!
Así que chicos,
no se olviden de votar.
¡Gracias!